this modeling career has been insane
what has been a highlight for you
what was the highlight for me was that
you know having big brands take a chance
on me after so many years uh friends say
no and no and no you know balenciaga
believing in me was really amazing and
all you know even alexander wang
everyone's just been so incredible to me
so i think
being able to just execute and live my
best life and know that everyone is on
the same page to just
make an amazing outfit and just have fun
walking in the balenciaga show i mean
that was iconic how did that feel for
you
it felt crazy because i was i was so
different than myself you know that was
like stripped down christina aguilera
style you know it was a different
version of me but it was it was fun and
i i didn't really have anxiety it was
just a great experience really
since announcing that you're not coming
back to selling sunset how are you
feeling do you feel relief
oh i feel so relieved honestly you know
i was we were all living this life for
so many years and it's it's wearing you
know and i'm just excited to finally be
doing the things that i love
and not have someone write my own lines
for me
i think that authenticity comes through
too like you just seem happier more
authentic now that you're going to be
pursuing modeling we got i have to say
we got the most iconic statement from
your publicist when you were leaving it
was like he's leaving to pursue modeling
well so what is next for you what is
your next step basically just being
around like-minded people like this in
the fashion community i mean i don't
have specific plans but i i would love
to be a creative director you know i
just i love fashion so much so
last question what has surprised you the
most about motherhood so far
i mean how hard it is but other than
that how rewarding it is you know um i
think just
watching him grow and you know teaching
him things it's so incredible and it's
just
i see myself in him and it's really nice